If you're trying to get rid of an old pair of shoes...
...or hoping to buy a pair on the cheap, you now have Japanese app Mercari.
Mercari.
The peer-to-peer marketplace app is gaining popularity in the US...
...as an alternative to Amazon or eBay.
In late July, the app shot up to number three in US download rankings,...
...a rare feat for a Japanese start-up in the US.
Some US users say it's easy to use...
...and they like that there's no commission for selling items.
Mercari has built a niche in Japan among women in their twenties and thirties...
...who are using it to buy and sell cosmetics, bags, and used clothes.
Mercari introduced its US version in 2014.
The company says Apple, Nike, Pink, Victoria's Secret and Michael Kors...
...are the most popular brands on its US site.